eyewitness testimony of course is the
single greatest cause of the conviction
of the innocent and what's fascinating
about that is that we have now 30 years
more than 30 years of fantastic research
from experimental psychologists who have
you know recreated crime scene recreated
events and played around with which
different way we do a photo array or a
lineup and different techniques that are
used correlate more with accurate and
reliable identification and which
techniques lead to errors and a number
of reforms have been adopted by federal
Commission's and American Bar
Association the International
Association of Chiefs of Police lapse of
policing entities based on really good
scientific research I mean a lot of this
research there's meta analyses that's
where you pull together lots of
different studies and you have a lot of
confidence that certain things are real
effects and I'll give you some examples
that may surprise people for example
before you show somebody a photo array
or a live lineup you should tell the
witness we're now going to show you some
pictures or people please keep in mind
that the real perpetrator may or may not
be in this photo array or a lineup and
if you don't make an identification
don't worry the investigation will
continue just giving that morning
dramatically reduces incorrect
identification without really reducing
correct identifications and that's of
extraordinary importance obviously in
terms of being able to go out find the
real perpetrator and not arrest the
wrong person there's lots of reasons we
think that this warning will reduce era
certainly it inhibits people from
guessing and there's kind of a natural
inclination to do that another reform
that's of really critical importance
is that the person that administers the
lineup of the photo array should be
double blinded that is to say that the
person should not know who the suspect
is and that's important for many reasons
not the least of which is the
possibility of feedback confirming
feedback what again meta analyses have
shown is that if you say to somebody off
you picked that number to good or give
some kind of confirming feedback whether
you're a law enforcement person or
somebody else frankly what this does is
it can falsely inflate the person's
certainty that they made the correct
identification the witnesses believed
that they had a good opportunity to
observe the witness's belief that they
were paying attention when the crime was
committed all of these factors by the
way certainty opportunity to observe
paying attention are all factors that
the courts used to be using for views
frankly in trying to weigh the
reliability of identification when we
know that let's say some suggestive
procedure has been used so positive and
unduly suggestive procedure can falsely
inflate these so-called reliability
factors a certainty opportunity to
observe the tension paid and the legal
tests are out of whack with what the
scientific evidence shows
more than a year ago now the National
Academy of Science came out with a
report about forensic science generally
extremely important report a landmark
report that anybody really interested in
this field should look at and this
report basically said look DNA testing
is the only validated forensic
discipline we have and in particular
when you look at pattern evidence and by
this they were talking about
fingerprints and tire tracks and looking
at striations on bullets and trying to
determine
excuse me whether they came from a gun
particular gun or not all these pattern
disciplines had not been adequately
validated because you would have it
coming into court and saying I'm looking
at the striations of this bullet that we
recovered from the crime scene and now I
found this defendants gun and I fired a
bullet from that and I'm looking at the
two of them under a microscope and I see
all these lines and I think there's
quote/unquote sufficient agreement and
by that and if I'm really a big Quality
Assurance lab I'll bring my buddy in and
he'll look at the microscope and he'll
say I think there's also agreement here
and from this I can now tell you that
this bullet came from that gun to the
exclusion of all other guns in the
universe well think about it
scientifically on what basis do you have
a database can you tell us anything
about the frequency of fiying similar
patterns if indeed you have similar
patterns do you have measurement error
here can you give the same number you
know with DNA testing we can give you a
number we can give you the frequency of
a particular DNA profile in various
different populations can you give us a
statistic and the answer is no they
weren't giving statistics as a matter of
fact they were just saying it's unique
this bullet comes from that gun to the
exclusion of all guns in the universe
this is nonsense and the National
Academy of Science said so and say you
guys have really got to go back to the
drawing board and do some basic research
to find out what the answers are to that
question even fingerprints which we know
when if you take all ten prints and you
scan it in and you put it into a data
database of known
fingerprints you can do a pretty good
job of identifying somebody that that's
not the question when you're talking
about a small latent print at a crime
scene you get a partial thumbprint let's
say and every time you lay down a print
it's always a little bit uneven and then
you compare it to somebody else's
thumbprint can you say that this small
latent uniquely comes from that
individual well that is the way that
testimony was going in four years and it
was a without scientific basis to say
that it uniquely was this person's print
you can't say that